the jurogan experience you know
uh les stroud yeah uh so he did that
show
about survivor man bigfoot yeah but it
just went away
bro that show i love love
yeah love survivor man that show was so
[ __ ] dumb
yeah he had a guy on the show that
is known in the bigfoot world as being
full of [ __ ]
yeah which is bad like if the bigfoot
world's pretty open-minded yeah
this is one of the things that i wanted
to bring up about that 411 the hunted
thing
there's audio recording that was
supposedly
taken from the 1970s
from northern california um
i wanna say sonoma
i don't remember where it was somewhere
in northern california but it's called
they call them the uh
samurai sounds the samurai and it's the
weirdest [ __ ] ever man
it's like these guys had this spot that
they would go
into the into the mountains and they
would hunt every year
and they built the structure out there
and then they brought recording
equipment
and they claimed to have recorded sounds
of these animals these bigfoot and that
these bigfoot were around them all the
time while they were up there
now what's crazy about it is the sounds
are so weird
it sounds like someone pretending to be
japanese that
doesn't actually speak japanese yeah
have you ever heard it no
we'll play it for you it's because it's
the weirdest [ __ ] it's
it sounds so strange and so
fake but you know like they have these
quote-unquote experts that say the human
voice is not capable
of making sounds remotely similar to
this the range is
which doesn't make any sense if you know
who michael winslow is
yeah right yeah yeah that guy who yeah
that guy went on he does a woman peeing
when she goes to the bathroom
he does everything he does everything he
did led zeppelin he played whole lot of
love with his mouth
and it sounds incredible but um this
samurai sound like
there's these loud whoops whoops and
these guys are like
in the foreground you know like the guys
who are recording they're trying to
communicate with these things
they sound so calm i mean if there
really was
giant [ __ ] eight foot apes out there
wandering around like you know two three
hundred yards away from you screaming
and whooping and talking
would you really and you're in the woods
would you really be so calm
wouldn't you be freaking the [ __ ] out
these guys
do you have it yeah i'm trying to make
sure i find the right thing because i'm
stumbling across
some traps oh but people are making
[ __ ] around the internet
i wish i could remember the gentleman's
name well i think i have it that's all
i'm saying so
ronald j morehead and alan berry maybe
is that right yes
ron moorhead yeah yeah that's it the
sierra mountains that's what it is
and so um it's the weirdest [ __ ] ever
listen just listen to this you're gonna
i read what it could be but we'll listen
first it could be [ __ ] yeah
all aboard
stop this is a terrible version of it
there's a better version of it where you
can hear the guys really clearly
the people talking i don't know why
that's so scratchy
but they're like they're over by the
lake
like they're talking like that
this very strange sound and they're
coming calm about it
yeah and these you know supposed vocal
experts are analyzing it the human body
is incapable of making such
sounds
you know and that area of you got it i
don't know it says hd
okay we'll hear it here yeah
they're knocking that's another thing
that sasquatch do
they knock
that one's weird
scoot ahead a little bit and hear the
samurai sounds
still sounds terrible anyway
these people believe that [ __ ] less
drought was balls deep in this
guy apparently he had an experience and
i talked to him about his experiences
pretty interesting
he was in um not with that guy but he
was in alaska
and uh apparently he heard some crazy
noises like some monkey sounds outside
of his
in the middle of nowhere no one's ever
in there and he said he heard something
run away
some bipedal sound of something running
away
but again even though he's an
experienced woodsman
and he's a guy who's you know camped out
countless nights in the middle of
nowhere and survives in the middle of
nowhere and documents it like
he's the reason why those survivor shows
exist yeah because that guy literally
would starve to death and try to eat
like
bark and whatever the [ __ ] he could
recep you could see his face like
sinking in as he was losing weight
i mean he really did do that he did all
sorts of different things to try to
survive
and then documented how he was doing it
what he would do
but he got obsessed with bigfoot and
then developed that bigfoot show
and unfortunately a lot of people lost a
lot of faith in him because of that
they're like no you're the legit
survivor guy
and now you're doing this show and this
is why it's ridiculous there was one
episode of the show where they had this
guy who he was with who had video
of the sasquatch like high definition
video
and it looks so fake yeah it's like
he's like the sasquatch is looking at
him through the woods and he's like
there he is there he is that's a guy
with a mascot that's sorry
he goes out i'm a sasquatch like okay he
just pulled that out
yeah it makes the sandwich but
this you know the the guy who had the
video is known to be like full [ __ ] and
here he's got
this guy on a show and then he you know
is this real
you be the judge like yeah i'm gonna say
it's not real
it's a guy with a [ __ ] mask on i
think i did read that that that guy was
very
not respected yes in that by the bigfoot
community yeah
you know the bigfoot community again
very open-minded
yeah he marriages into everything this
other thing like
they would they would see trees that
would fall over
like in certain patterns and they were
convinced that sasquatch
was leaning these trees against each
other
i thought it was like yeah this is not
to let you know where not to go
yeah that's they had this idea i mean
it's all theory
right yeah i think i've been following
the wrong guy dude i believe all the
stuff that he likes fake i'm like
yeah i only watched that less strong one
because of that other guy
i want it to be real that's the thing i
do too if someone
had a convincing bigfoot encounter where
they caught it on video where i was like
holy [ __ ] what is that
like what is that or there was something
but there's nothing
like i you know i've i've talked to a
lot of those people when i did this show
called joe rogan questions everything
for sci-fi and me and duncan trussell
actually went camping in the pacific
northwest
we didn't really camp we pretended to go
camping and then we went to a hotel yeah
and then we came back
the next morning like well rough night
of camping yeah yeah but we're out there
for days
trying to look for sasquatch and talking
to people that hunt for sasquatch
and the one conclusion that we came to
is it's a bunch of unfuckable white
dudes
like yeah just out there camping
it's just but the the desire for it to
be real is so strong
it's it would change i watched you know
like that finding bigfoot show
i used to always think because people
like why is it on i'm like i don't know
man because it's fun to watch and if
they find him the world is different now
like if they come back with bigfoot
everything's different everything's good
everything's getting different with the
alien thing
yeah the fact that they're saying it's
that that's like true you're like
it's a lot dude that's a lot to take if
we get
you know i know that they have the
videos and stuff that aliens but like if
you if we get up straight up start
talking to one
i mean i don't know what's gonna happen
well here's something that came out
uh today jamie i'm gonna send you this
uh because uh
sauger and jetty from uh rising on the
hill and i've been going back and forth
with this and
i i found this today and sent it to him
it's um
i'll send it to you right now jamie
um it says paradigm shifting ufo
tech that alters space time is operable
u.s navy chief tech officer so it's some
story that i didn't bother looking into
it because i
saw it when i was on my way out the door
and i was like what in the [ __ ]
is this because there's been all these
sightings of these things that move
in some weird way paradigm shifting ufo
tech there
so there's these things that been that
move in this weird way that don't show
any propulsion system
and uh due to censorship please join us
on telegram
i'm going to say documents obtained by
the drive show the revolutionary
technology that has capability to alter
space-time
may actually be operable according to
the naval aviation enterprise
chief technology officer dr james
how do you say that name sheehy poison
comparable in quotes
what is that i don't know good question
reflect on
why is technology that has a potential
to change the entire human
experience for the better always used
for the defense purposes and military
applications
what are the betterments what about the
betterment of humanity
yeah i don't know um
but it's christopher mellon who's that
guy who keeps coming up with all this uh
ufo tech stuff
can you scroll back up please someone's
just like writing i was reading through
twitter
it's like a story it's not really like
an article
right um twitter feed of christopher
mellon the former deputy assistant
defense secretary for intelligence from
97 to 2002
doing so i came across an interesting
post from the drive
regarding documents they received via
the freedom of freedom of information
act
regarding a space-time modification
weapon
developed by the u.s navy which
apparently has already gone through
experimental testing
this in turn led me to evidence
suggesting that other
revolutionary type of technology that
could no doubt be used to change the
world for the better blah blah blah was
already operable
yeah i don't know but does this is what
uh if you pay attention to the ufo world
do you pay attention to that [ __ ] at all
uh not like actively there's a guy named
bob lazar
i didn't know that from because you
talked to him yeah
it was one of the weirdest conversations
i've ever had because you're like i mean
are you crazy are you full of [ __ ] or is
this real
yeah because if it is real this thing is
a uh special effect created a guy who is
a special effect artist
remember his name jamie who made this
thing for us
this gentleman he's got a
um design
designs by perry designs by perry at
instagram
and he created this thing and this is
like a scale model of what bob lazar
supposedly worked on
he was hired by the united states
military to
work at area s4 which is part of the
area 51 area 51
site s4 site for was
this place where he allegedly
worked to back engineer these spaceships
and the way these things moved around
was exactly how this christopher mellon
guy or this article rather
that quoted him as describing that they
used some sort of
gravity space-time bending technology
so they didn't use a propulsion system
like a rocket shoots flame out the back
they bent time in front of them and just
would shoot instantaneously
to wherever the [ __ ] they wanted to go
so you should be like instantly be able
to go
instantly what's [ __ ] is that there
was an instance
off of the uh coast of san diego in 2004
where a navy pilot uh by the name of
commander david fravor who i've also had
on the show
experienced this thing that they call
the tic tac ufo
they tracked it with radar they tracked
it with
their the camera systems on the on the
on the on their plane and they even have
the video footage of this thing
it went from 80 000 feet above sea level
to one in a second wow that's the amount
of time that it takes radar to do the
blip pip
yeah so in that time it traveled
80 000 feet they have no idea how the
[ __ ] it did that it shows no
propulsion heat signature they took
video footage of this thing and it went
from there it took off where they
couldn't even file with their eye just
disappeared to the predetermined
destination where they were supposed to
coordinate later
so it's like it's reading their tracking
systems or reading where
they were going and the people that
worked on the aircraft carrier were
telling
the fighter pilot like we've been seeing
these things
over you know we see them like every
couple weeks we have no idea what the
[ __ ] going on yeah
and they they just say well there it is
you know what are we gonna do about that
yeah yeah i like to picture the like an
alien in that
tic tac he's like well slow it down dude
you're kind of crazy right now like
he's having a bad day because he's got
to be having just a day
whoever's in there some kind of day
maybe having a day
that's it's a lot to yeah i don't you
think it's like a lot to just tell
people like if they had to be like to
tell like just
earth all of us humans on earth to like
wrap our head around
what would happen i think what do you
say
if that's all you know like if you are
the military
and all you know is that something can
do these things
something can move at the speed you know
the new york times had a front page
article about that a couple years ago
and um but basically they're saying
hey you know there are videos
of things moving in a way that we don't
understand that aren't exhibiting a heat
signature
that indicates a propulsion system we
don't know what it is
and this is then the the there's uh the
covet 19 bill
that just got passed and one of the
provisions in the code 19 bill was that
they have 60
60 no 180 days to release
all the information they have about ufos
that's a lot you know but i don't know
if they're going to do anything but i
think they're going to do that that's
funny that's in this
yeah we don't have an teen bill yeah
like that's a lot of weird [ __ ] was yeah
19 bill like like foreign aid there's a
lot of foreign
aid to pakistan aid to all these
countries it's like people just
to get it passed they're like okay i'll
we'll say yes but i want you to do a
little
little favor for me and put this in the
bill yeah and there's you know just
shows you how greasy politicians are
yeah yeah it's kind of crazy
yeah yeah but that's allegedly
what ufo technology is wow catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience